do you exercise yes love making and
woodworking do you have any history of
mental illness in your family I have an
uncle who does yoga allergies cowardice
and weak-willed Men
and hazelnuts sexual history epic and
private
[Music]
land good morning Jerry that is a
beautiful sweater vest April
you look like you could use twenty
dollars am I right why because you're a
kid and kids always need money I need
money Ah that's why you're my favorite
Tom when Tiger Woods feels Invincible he
wears a red shirt and black pants Good
morning Deputy Ron wears the same thing
after he's had sex
you've aged horribly
you
son of a oh my God what is your
problem nothing
I did okay
okay we're fine we're fine take it easy
when you meddle in someone's personal
life it's just so rewarding
oh yes
it usual place
[Laughter]
it is rough in here is it always like
this I wouldn't know don't like strip
clubs
smells like a wet mop in here and I get
the feeling that every one of these
women is running a low-grade fever
you're one of the good ones Ron
hello beautiful
[Music]
strippers do nothing for me I like a
strong salt of the earth self-possessed
woman at the top of her field your
stuffy graphs your Cheryl swoopses
but I will take a free breakfast buffet
Anytime Anyplace
I'm a simple man
I like pretty dark-haired women and
breakfast food but this stock photo I
bought at a framing store isn't real
today I got the real thing
a naked Tammy made me breakfast this
morning
I should have taken a picture of it
so how are you feeling Tom are you
feeling okay I like pretending to be sad
I now see why girls do it so your
arrangement with Wendy it really was
completely platonic yeah never so much
has even kissed except for a little Peck
at the wedding ceremony for appearances
uh now that you're getting divorced I
sort of feel like there may be some
potential with me and Wendy
would it be okay with you if I was to
ask her out once the fake dust settles
yeah
um why not sure
looking at her I feel like
she might be the perfect spooning size
for me
I'm gonna take a leak
as she was burned at the stake Joan of
Arc did not cower
she did not beg for mercy she said in a
strong clear voice I am not afraid
I was born to do this I want to be
burned at the stick many societal
institutions were established solely to
oppress women to this day some feminists
have even condemned marriage as a
glorified form of slavery amen foreign
class was awesome I wholeheartedly agree
if that woman weren't so violently
opposed to marriage I think I would
propose to her
he's already bored of course you are
you're not challenging yourself
I suggest we sample a few more classes
bye everybody guess what I was secretly
an undercover rock star this whole time
for what it's worth I think you would
make an incredible brunette
Ron Swanson
[Music]
whale tail whale tail she's flashing a
whale tail abort abort hello Tammy
hi Ron I didn't see you come in I was
just checking myself for scoliosis and
straight is narrow
just like somebody else I know
jerky call off the dogs you and I both
know that in my entire adult life I have
never checked a book out of the library
[Music]
oh
it's been like this for hours
Ron's got one just like it on his penis
what the hell happened to you
[Music]
I got it you may now kiss the bride
oh
yeah
it's been kind of a crazy night
come back
[Music]
shaped off part of your mustard mustard
that's lovely I didn't shave it off it
rubbed off
from friction
uh
she just knows you so well I was
starting to wonder if I was ever going
to get to that point
I'm worried that maybe there isn't room
in your life for another woman at this
very moment Leslie is throwing herself
in front of a freight train named Tammy
for me and you Leslie is a wonderful
loyal friend who's very important in my
life but I would sooner visit Europe
than I have something romantic happen
between us
although if you would like to visit
Europe
I like you so much I'd be willing to
risk it
but not friends right
right now
see you know me pretty well already but
you're about to get to know me even
better I brought you here because I want
to show you something
that almost no one knows about certainly
not Tammy and not even Leslie Knope
ladies and gentlemen
only my man Mr Duke silver
I might be fine holiday evening to you
all
it might be cold outside
but it's about to get warm all up in my
jazz
I of course am Duke silver
and I would like to dedicate this first
song
to my duchess
[Music]
I'm going to kill you